is it easy being a second-generation
filmmaker with all the expectations and
people's opinions about whatever it is
by now it's very hard to answer that
question because that's where I came
from and I didn't come from somewhere
else so I don't really know the
difference between is it easy I mean I
is anybody's family like particularly
awesomely easy some people I guess but I
mean I've live in a family of artists
who all are you know we're up and down
and thing but no I mean yes yes no yes
no iba it gives people i I got the best
lesson I got the best film school I got
fat I got movies made in my house I got
to see a way of making films from my
parents that was a style that I could
relate to which is very grassroots very
like everybody come together and let's
do something great not like let's do it
for the money or let's do you know it
was a very the intention was so pure you
know and that time was so influential to
me as a writer and director yes but is
something that I wanted like a that
style that family that feeling that I
wanted and it felt so right and so
comfortable so that part is so great and
you know I don't know I mean people are
very critical you know and they expect
you i await you don't make as good as
movie is John Cassavetes like well I
only made one movie can i get to make
more movies and maybe you know you'll
like more my movies because i was
talking about there's that experience
that you have to have you keep learning
you keep getting better you keep and you
have to have the ability I mean it to be
able to make them you know is people
need to help you make these films so you
can show you know it's a big circle so I
mean yes and no yes no yes what would
your advice be to someone else who's of
a second-generation film acting creative
family where they don't need my advice
if and through their that you know
they know what it's all about if you're
born into it you you know what it's all
about it's nice to maybe come together
and relate for a second but I mean
there's such awesome things about it and
there's
really shitty things about it and you
know obviously we're not out there like
advertising all the shitty things you
know about it but you know I would say
like it's the key that opens the door
but you got to turn the doorknob you
know well you're still human being so
you still have to go to functions and
you still have to put your work out
there so you talked in another interview
about being the cheerleader of your own
project so knowing that there are
pressures how do you be that you know in
that what are you doing to beat your own
drum so to speak in it's a bad metaphor
but what are you doing because I'm sure
that it is difficult and there are
expectations or people's jealousies
whatever I mean whatever and so the
people are so jealous not jealous and
people say awful things they tweet you
awful things they send facebook thing
awful things awful things they say awful
things to you about who they think you
are and how why are you doing this and
you should come from a rich you come
from a family does it look like my
family made a lot of trust fund movies I
mean I mean did you ever see a movie of
my parents you know I mean it's like
there's no so there's all these
perceptions about how glamorous and how
much money you have and how it's like
I've been supporting myself for many
many years you know I had real jobs i
work i did everything so there's that
you know but you have to let that go and
you have to be like you know people are
either people always going to think what
they want to think and you can you know
raise your hands and scream and light
yourself on fire and say I'm not that
person and they are gonna believe you're
not so I don't really worry about that
so much although it does kind of get you
down sometimes because you're just kind
of trying to fight the good fight but
you know if you want to do something you
should you have to realize that the
criticism is out there too so it's a
balance I think the quote is like I
think does it tere kol Whitacre wrote a
book what other people think of me is
none of my business that's good one yeah
I need to read that okay i think i'll
write it too let's we get to each other
okay
you